[Music]
okay everybody so this is my
spoiler-free review of season one of
halo so
just to make clear they have only sent
the first two episodes to critics for
halo season one so it's so hard when you
do this because i'm only basing this off
of two episodes but that's what we got
right so that's what i can judge it off
of but i want to say that i am a huge
fan of the halo games i grew up playing
the first three games and i've spent
many hours playing the multiplayer of
halo and i actually prefer local
multiplayer and i've had some of the
best memories playing this game with
friends some of the most joy it's
brought me so i was really excited for
this show i had lower expectations
because i was a little worried about the
trailers i wasn't sure how i felt about
it but it's exciting about stephen
spielberg is an executive producer on
this even though it's from a distance
his creative control he's been trying to
get this made for years it has been in
developmental hell for almost a decade
so it's exciting it actually has
happened now seeing the first two
episodes i gotta say i was pretty
impressed by this now i think without
i'm not going to spoil anything here so
don't worry about that so what i'm going
to say is that
i think that this show actually leans
more towards halo fans that maybe its
weaknesses it's not i don't think gonna
be as appealing as just a regular tv
show to someone who's not a halo fan but
i think
it does right by the halo fans and that
audience and that what keeps me
intrigued is having played the games i
get a little bit of those nerd chills
coming in when i see certain things that
you'll see appear just in the first two
episodes alone now the show looks great
it looks better than it did in the
trailers i was thoroughly impressed by
that and it has some exciting action
sequences but what will get you excited
is that it focuses on character and it
puts value in writing so
that gives me hope for this season right
and i think it was a smart decision the
show runners have said that they want to
make the show its own entity in the halo
universe but not can into the game so
they're keeping it separate so that the
games don't rely on the show and vice
versa which i think was smart and you'll
see that and they're kind of putting
their own twist on the tail of master
chief here which i think really works
and the way they're doing it is angling
for it to work as a tv series which is
smart you know they're not making the
bible the game story which i like and
you'll see pablo schreiber who plays
master chief does a great job already
one of the complaints i do have though
from watching it is he's very
very similar to the mandalorian the
character and how he kind of comes off
with his mask on that's my only critique
and it's not something i can really hold
against the show but the mandalorians
the most popular show in the world so
you know you're not going to help but
notice these things it's very soon so
that's one of my critiques but again
he's great at the role it's just a
little similar you know flies a little
closer to the sun to the mandalorian the
show but again it's not something it's
not a bad idea right to be inspired by a
show that works really well in many ways
and you'll see a lot of star wars
inspiration in the show in general i do
think the premiere is a little stronger
than episode two but you'll see in
episode two there's a lot of mystery
built in and i really don't want to
spoil anything but there's a lot of cool
stuff they're doing and you're kind of
wondering even as a halo fan like okay
where are they going to go with this but
it's intriguing and every character is
getting a character arc there's not
paper thin characters here and even the
villains they're getting motivation and
you're kind of seeing it slowly build
they're giving you little bread crumbs
it's a little slow at parts and you
might zone out a bit at parts but it
sucks you right back in when you start
feeling that again because really good
acting all around too and the characters
that are the side characters here that
are you know they're building to be main
characters they have great chemistry
with master chief and they're all
likable there's no one i'm rolling my
eyes at which i'm relieved by you know
and they're good young actresses here
and young actors and
i see full potential for this to be a
great full season so again when you're
seeing these season one reviews come out
it's only based on the first two
episodes but my overall score for it is
going to be an 8.2
i'm gonna give the premiere an 8.7 and
episode two will bring down to just like
an eight so it kind of i'm gonna bring
this all as a whole to an 8.2 but that's
only based on the first two episodes but
it's exciting stuff i think this show is
going to be a hit with halo fans for
sure and honestly just sci-fi fans it is
very sci-fi but if you're out of that
realm i don't think this show really is
something you'd be interested in but
give it a try but if you like you know
star wars stuff if you like bad star
galactica stuff i think you'll like it
if you like anything based off video
games and of course if you like halo i
think this succeeds i don't think halo
fans are gonna be angry about this i
know i'm not i think this is way better
than i thought and you know what for a
video game tv adaptation where there's
not a lot of good adaptations of video
game anything
this is pretty solid so
it could go either way though this is
the first two episodes so you know i
could see it falling off
midway and coming off the rails or i
could see it getting better so i think
it has
the tools here to be a really good show
and i think from the first two episodes
i'm impressed and it's way better than i
thought it would be so i'm excited to
see what you guys think about it let me
know if you plan on watching it if what
you are expecting to see what you're
excited to see let me know i'll be doing
reviews of it every week so make sure to
subscribe i'm gonna review every single
episode and please follow me at steve
varley show on twitter instagram and
tick tock for more of me and i'll see
you next time